[Music]
at 33 17:33 protocol accepted
daddy's listening can you say hi and how
big are you I mean can you tell that how
big you are are you so big your brain
and can you sing but singing how about I
miss you and I love you I love you daddy
I love me daddy and I can't wait to see
who can you say see you Huyen panpipe I
[Music]
detected this is UNSC Pelican echo 216
can you hear me
this is you Ellis
[Music]
[Music]
looks like the main power cells are
fried auto shutdown triggering survival
mode I'm going to try to overwrite
okay
you can hear me in there
I hope you're ready please or die
Oh welcome back chief
I rerouted what little power ahead into
your suit hmm looks like there's a
problem with the servos in your hands
stay calm
you've been out there a while I know I
saw something in here to check your
armors Diagnostics oh you see there big
guy
no not status report status report what
there's something you need to see chief
we lost
lost everything
there's nothing left for us
in four years
[Music]
not this not again we need to run
no we need to fight
get ready
[Music]
I chose you because you were special
[Music]
I knew we would be perfect together
and I was right
[Music]